bonjour à tous je vous propose de suivre
aujourd'hui l'examen du projet de loi
sur l'égalité femmes hommes
un texte examiné au sénat en deuxième
lecture après avoir été adopté par
l'assemblée nationale
alors sachez que la commission des lois
du sénat a adopté plusieurs amendements
sur ce texte
le renforcement des dispositifs de
protection des victimes de violences en
prévoyant notamment que l' ordonnance de
protection doit être délivré en urgence
à une femme menacées de mariage forcé la
prise en compte de la sociologie de
certaines professions dans la poursuite
de l'objectif de parité et enfin la
suppression de plusieurs dispositifs
déjà satisfait par le droit en vigueur
comme par exemple l'obligation de
formation des élèves d'écoles de
journalisme ou d'art voilà sachez enfin
que la commission des lois a rejeté un
amendement du groupe ump qui tendait à
revenir pour le recours à une
interruption volontaire de grossesse à
une ivg à l'exigence d'une situation de
détresse pour la femme enceinte
voilà tout de suite je vous propose de
se diriger vers l'hémicycle l'ordre du
jour appelle la discussion deuxième
lecture du projet de loi modifié par
l'assemblée nationale pour l'égalité
réelle entre les hommes et les femmes
je voulais rajouter madame la présidente
que c'est un réel rappel au règlement ce
qui n'est pas le cas le plus souvent je
l'aï signalé quand même dans la
discussion générale la parole et à
madame najat vallaud belkacem ministre
des droits des femmes de la ville de la
jeunesse et des sports
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
président de la commission des lois
mesdames les rapporteurs madame la
présidente de la délégation aux droits
des femmes
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs
avant de commencer une réaction sur
votre rappel au règlement madame la
présidente de la délégation aux droits
des femmes auquel j'aurais du mal à ne
pas souscrire je partage évidemment tout
ce que vous venez de dire et il est
important en effet que votre assemblée
puisse se saisir de cette convention
d'istanbul que nous puissions la
ratifier rapidement et que nous soyons
parce que c'est tout l'enjeu pour nous
le dixième états membres de cette
convention d'istanbul à la ratifier pour
lui donner toute sa force et entraîné
dans notre dynamique bien d'autres pays
donc je tiens à vous dire bien sûr c'est
une décision qui appartient la
conférence des présidents que la
fixation du calendrier
donc il lui appartient désormais de
fixer une autre date je crois avoir
compris qu'une autre date est d'ores et
déjà trouvé qui serait le 5 mai prochain
ce qui me rassure res signifierait que
nous n'aurions plus longtemps à attendre
mais en tout cas je vous remercie de
votre remarque
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs il y
a maintenant sept mois et figurez-vous
que c'était sept mois jour pour jour
nous achevions dans cet hémicycle
l'examen en première lecture du projet
de loi dont nous allons reparler
aujourd'hui le projet de loi pour
l'égalité entre les femmes et les hommes
au commencement du très riche débat que
nous avions eue alors pendant toute une
semaine j'avais souligné à quel point la
république avait laissé trop longtemps
la moitié des français en l'occurrence
les françaises en dehors de sa promesse
fondatrice d'égalité j'ai noté que votre
commission des lois avait dans le titre
du projet de loi supprimer cet adjectif
réel qui avaient été rajoutés par
l'assemblée nationale pour afficher ses
convictions
une suppression qui n'est évidemment pas
la marque d'un manque d'ambition puisque
votre commission a par ailleurs
largement démontrée par son travail sa
volonté de recentrer notre texte sur les
lieux
les plus décisifs de l'égalité une
suppression donc qui je crois reflète
davantage une conviction que je partage
car c'est l'esprit même du texte que
nous allons examiner ici en seconde
lecture que de dire qu'il ne saurait y
avoir de droit sans l'effectivité des
droits
il ne saurait y avoir non plus de
promesse républicaine d'égalité sans la
volonté farouche d'une égalité dans les
faits vécus au quotidien par les
françaises et les français
vous le savez cette égalité dans les
faits cette égalité réelle je les
intégrer comme une exigence prioritaire
de l'action publique que je conduis cela
passe d'abord par la mise en oeuvre et
l'application stricte des lois qui
existent déjà
c'est la mission à laquelle je m'emploie
chaque jour au gouvernement depuis
maintenant presque deux ans
l'égalité dans les faits l'égalité
réelle cela passe aussi par
l'approfondissement des droits quand la
pratique nous montrent que nous n'avons
pas été assez loin et c'est l'ambition
de ce texte que des travaux
parlementaires ont pu enrichir sur
chacun de ces volets s'assurer que les
lois sont effectives les renforcer pour
aller plus loin figurez-vous que c'était
exactement ce message qui a été passé
hier même par le président de la
république qui avec un panel de
nouvelles maire élu de notre pays est
venu célébrer hier le 70e anniversaire
de l' ordonnance du 21 avril 1944 qui
accordait enfants le droit de vote et
d'éligibilité aux femmes
le hasard de calendrier est assez
heureux puisque nous nous retrouvons le
lendemain et je le prends ce hasard de
calendrier comme une invitation à la
réflexion et à l'action
rappelons-nous en particulier que nous
célébrons donc aujourd'hui ce qui fut il
ya 70 ans
l'acte fondateur de cette première
génération de droits des femmes
celle de la reconnaissance de leur
pleine citoyenneté
celle pour reprendre les mots du très
engagé et fernand grenier
celle par laquelle la république
renaissante manifesté à l'égard de la
femme française la volonté il est il de
ne plus la traiter en mineur de ne plus
la traiter en inférieur rappelons-nous
donc qu'avec ce projet de loi dont nous
discutons
aujourd'hui ce que nous avons la
responsabilité collective de construire
c'est une nouvelle génération des droits
des femmes pour une société plus forte
parce que elle se sera donné l'ambition
et les moyens de réaliser pour chacune
et pour chacun la promesse de l'égalité
comme le déclare notre constitution
avancée avancer toujours en matière de
droits des femmes
nous le devons pour ne pas reculer et
cela vaut aussi dans cette seconde
lecture du texte
c'est cela le combat pour l'égalité
entre les sexes
je le dis sans détour les évolutions
dans un certain nombre de pays voisins
pourtant par le passé à la pointe du
combat pour l'égalité entre les femmes
et les hommes
les évolutions récentes donc on crée une
certaine inquiétude
elle nous montre que nous ne sommes pas
à l'abri d'un retour en arrière que tout
défaut de vigilance
toute faiblesse dans l'approfondissement
et la consolidation des droits acquis
sont autant de brèches ouvertes aux
vents mauvais de la régression des
droits des femmes à disposer librement
de leur corps a décidé librement de leur
vie a été chèrement acquis il sera
chèrement protéger votre commission a
approuvé la suppression de la référence
à la situation de détresse qui
conditionnait jusqu alors l'accès à
l'ivg et g c'est une actualisation
bienvenue de notre droit
elle s'appuie sur la jurisprudence du
conseil d'état qui dès 1981 avait vidé
cette condition de toute effectivité
je ne vous apprends rien en confortant
cela vous êtes en phase avec la très
grande majorité des français
restons dans ce consensus le droit à
l'interruption volontaire de grossesse
nous l'avons construit ensemble
il fait partie désormais de notre
patrimoine commun préservons le et
protégeons le ensemble au cours de la
navette
le projet de loi s'est étoffé au risque
peut-être parfois d'en atténuer les
lignes de force
alors permettez moi de saluer le travail
des rapporteurs qui ont eu le souci de
la sélectivité pour que l'émergence des
idées n'altère pas les priorités du
texte les priorités du texte
nous le savons c'est l'égalité
professionnelle c'est la lutte contre
les discriminations entre femmes et
hommes au travail c'est la lutte contre
les violences et les stéréotypes
sexistes la lutte contre la précarité
l'égal accès aux responsabilités
politiques sociales et professionnelles
pour les femmes et les hommes
le défi de l'égalité professionnelle
d'abord le projet de loi le relève ce
défi à travers la réforme ambitieuse du
congé parental avec une double ambition
que votre assemblée d'ailleurs avait
approfondi des le premier examen
première ambition s'adapter aux familles
en leur ouvrant de nouvelles
possibilités pour construire de nouveaux
équilibres deuxième ambition tout faire
pour remettre les femmes sur le chemin
de l'emploi
les travaux parlementaires ont nettement
enrichis cette réforme en permettant
d'aller plus loin je pense en
particulier à l'expérimentation d'un
congé optionnel plus court et mieux
rémunéré dont votre commission a très
justement réajuster le calendrier
je pense aussi aux mesures prises pour
s'adapter aux parents comme la prise en
compte de la situation des parents de
triplés et je sais madame dini que vous
avez proposé d'aller plus loin
concernant les parents de jumeaux c'est
un choix sur lequel le gouvernement vous
suivre avec cette réforme
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs j'en
suis convaincu cette réforme du congé
parental j'en suis convaincu une
dynamique se créera pour agir
progressivement sur les comportements
sur la répartition des tâches pour
favoriser l'égalité dans les
organisations de travail dans les
responsabilités domestiques aussi et
c'est parce que nous voulons ce
changement de comportement parce que
nous l'accompagnons par un effort inédit
en matière de solution de garde pour les
parents que je suis attaché à ce que la
réforme concerne toutes les professions
tout comme je suis attaché aux mesures
qui sont de nature à lever les freins à
l'utilisation du congé de paternité et
d'accueil de l'enfant je voulais dire
l'emploi des femmes est une
préoccupation majeure de cette réforme
en première lecture votre assemblée avec
introduit pour les salariés la
possibilité de bénéficier d'un entretien
avant même la reprise de postes est
prévue pour celles qui n'ont pas de
perspective immédiate de retour à
l'emploi
un dispositif d'accompagnement renforcé
et d'orientation pour leur permettre d'y
revenir
dans de meilleures conditions eh bien
j'ai le plaisir de vous annoncer que ce
dispositif comme je vous l'avais indiqué
en première lecture nous y avons
travaillé très activement ces derniers
mois et il sera désormais opérationnel
dès cette rentrée
pôle emploi d'une part la caisse
nationale d'allocations familiales de
l'autre ont mis au point avec moi une
nouvelle offre de formation
d'accompagnement vers l'emploi qui sera
généralisé sur tout le territoire d'ici
18 mois
c'est une offre qui permettra donc aux
salariés aux femmes aux hommes qui
prennent un congé parental qui leur
permettra de s'engager dans la
préparation de leur retour à l'emploi
un an avant la fin de leurs droits en
bénéficiant d'un bilan de compétences et
de propositions de formations sur mesure
pour pouvoir reprendre le travail dans
les meilleures conditions
c'est un changement important sur lequel
l'état s'engage et qui donne toute sa
crédibilité a l'ambition de notre
réforme du congé parental
je le rappelle à nouveau mieux partager
les responsabilités mais aussi réduire
l'éloignement du marché du travail
notamment des femmes l'égalité
professionnelle c'est aussi évidemment
celle qui se constituent dans les
entreprises au travers de la négociation
sur l'égalité négociations que votre
assemblée a rendu plus efficace
en transposant en première lecture de ce
texte l'accord national
interprofessionnel du 19 juin 2013
la dynamique de ce projet de loi pourra
s'appuyer sur les progrès que nous
enregistrons depuis maintenant plus d'un
an dans l'application effective des lois
sur l'égalité professionnelle puisque
vous le savez j'ai mis en place avec mon
collègue en charge du travail une
stratégie de contrôle et de sanction sur
les entreprises qui s'avère payante au
15 mars 2014 on enregistrait ainsi plus
de 5300 accords ou plans qui avait été
déposé à notre demande par les
entreprises auprès de l'administration
pour qu'elle puisse les instruire de
plans donc pour résorber les inégalités
constatées 762 entreprises ont été mises
en demeure pour n'avoir pas suffisamment
fait le travail ou pas fait le travail
du tout et 10 entreprises ont été
sanctionnés c'est à dire
après avoir été mise en demeure au bout
de six mois ne s'était toujours pas
conformer à leurs obligations
la sanction financière est alors tombé
pour 10 d'entre elles au delà de la peur
du gendarme
je le constate la pédagogie paye aussi
puisque 91 % des mises en demeure se
traduisent par des régularisations
je leur dis à ce stade nous ne visons
pas la sanction pour elles mêmes mais
pour rappeler aux entreprises que les
lois sur l'égalité ne peuvent pas être
des lois de seconde zone
quels doivent être appliquées comme
n'importe quelle loi et que nous le
contrôlons désormais strictement mais
notre stratégie au delà de cet aspect
peut paraître coercitif notre stratégie
est évidemment plus globale elle
consiste à traquer les discriminations
là où elles sont allées sanctionner
quand c'est nécessaire certes mais
surtout à permettre d analyse
circonstanciée à l'échelle de
l'entreprise
avec cet outil le rapport de situation
comparée qui était dans la loi depuis
quelques années déjà mais que nous avons
réformé que nous réformons dans le tac
dans le cadre de ce projet de loi
un rapport de situation comparée donc
qui permettra d'y voir plus clair sur la
réalité des inégalités leur diversité
aussi mais également avec toujours dans
notre texte
à l'échelle des branches des
négociations sur la classification
professionnelle puisque on le sait les
inégalités entre femmes et hommes sur le
marché du travail viennent aussi du fait
que femmes et hommes n'occupent pas les
mêmes emplois et que les métiers à
prédominance féminine sont souvent les
moins bien rémunérés
notre stratégie c'est aussi
d'accompagner les entreprises de leur
permettent de conduire chez elle une
vraie politique de lutte contre les
stéréotypes une vraie politique de
promotion de la mixité
c'est le sens de plusieurs évolutions
intervenues à l'assemblée nationale et
je me réjouis que votre commission les
airs prises elles sont extrêmement
utiles
certains des amendements que vous avez
déposé
vise à renforcer les sanctions sur les
entreprises qui ne respectent pas les
prescriptions en matière d'égalité
j'estime pour ma part que le texte issu
de l'assemblée nationale a atteint un
équilibre satisfaisant et que en
combinant le dispositif de contrôle
actuel que je viens d'évoquer en le
renforçant grâce à la mesure
d'interdiction d'accès à la commande
publique pour les entreprises qui ne
respectent pas leurs obligations en
matière d'égalité professionnelle en y
ajoutant les mesures d'accompagnement
que nous avons mises en place dans les
territoires sur lesquels je pourrais
revenir si vous voulez dans le débat
nous pouvons vraiment faire avancer
l'égalité professionnelle et salariale
assurer l'égalité c'est nécessairement
aussi lutter contre la précarité des
femmes
là aussi la volonté manifestée par ce
projet de loi de créer un nouveau
service public pour apporter demain une
garantie contre les impayés de pension
alimentaire cette volonté-là a rencontré
une véritable adhésion
du côté des familles monoparentales
sachez que nous avançons sur ce sujet
aussi 20 caf 20 caisses d'allocations
familiales soit un cinquième de
l'ensemble des caf de france
participeront à la préfiguration de ce
nouveau service public qu'elles sont
prêtes à engager avant qu'il ne se
généralise j'ai noté l'attention de
plusieurs d'entre vous pour que dans le
combat que nous menons contre ces
impayés de pension alimentaire
les victimes soient dispensés de la
prise en charge des frais d'huissier
c'est une excellente initiative que je
soutiens bien évidemment et pour
laquelle le gouvernement agira très vite
par la voie réglementaire puisque c'est
de ce niveau que cette question relève
j'en viens au troisième axe de ce projet
de loi-cadre savoir la lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes
tout ce volet est évidemment articulé
avec le plan de lutte contre les
violences faites aux femmes que j'ai
annoncé au mois de novembre dernier qui
est aujourd'hui mise en oeuvre je vous
rappelle que c'est un engagement
pluriannuel important que nous avons
pris puisqu'il va nous permettre de
mobiliser 66 millions d'euros en
articulation notamment avec la stratégie
nationale de prévention de la
délinquance
sachez que sur cette question d
la lutte contre les violences faites aux
femmes j'adhère aux évolutions proposées
par votre commission des lois je pense
en particulier à votre volonté
d'approfondir les conditions dans
lesquelles sont prises en compte les
enfants menacés par les violences au
sein du couple ainsi que autre sujet qui
me tient à coeur aussi la meilleure
protection apportée aux personnels des
chrs bénéfie hébergeant pardon des chs
hébergeant des femmes victimes de
violences j'adhère aussi aux évolutions
intervenues dans votre commission des
lois concernant les questions de
harcèlement moral sexuelle et en
particulier de harcèlement advenu à
l'université sujets qui méritent en
effet toute notre attention sur ce sujet
du harcèlement vous l'avez noté le
gouvernement à son tour déposé un
amendement que je défendrai tout à
l'heure qui modifie le code de la
défense pour transcrire dans le droit la
réponse très forte qu'à apporter mon
collègue jean yves le drian ministre en
charge de la défense à la suite de faits
caractérisés de harcèlement sexuel
vous le savez puisque votre haute
assemblée a été particulièrement engagés
dans la première loi que j'ai eu le
plaisir et le bonheur de vous présenter
à savoir la loi sur le harcèlement
sexuel avec christiane taubira vous le
savez donc notre politique en matière de
lutte contre le harcèlement est sans
ambiguïté c'est la tolérance zéro à
l'égard de ces faits d'ailleurs nos
échanges avait bien montré à l'époque la
gravité de ces faits donc cet amendement
que je vous présenterai modifiera le
code de la défense
comme nous l'avions fait à l'époque en
août 2012
s'agissant du statut général des
fonctionnaires ce sera un véritable
progrès et sa garantir à l'exemplarité
je l'espère de notre armée qui je le
rappelle à ce stade est aussi l'une des
armées les plus féminisées du monde
le travail de la navette a permis et je
m'en félicite d'apporter une réponse
aussi à quelques situations ambiguës
rencontrés par les femmes étrangères
victimes de violences
là aussi c'est une bonne chose aucune
femme ne doive se trouve se trouvait
dans cette alternative insupportable
subir les violences
de son conjoint ou subir une reconduite
à la frontière
lorsqu'une femme ne bénéficie d'un droit
de céaucé jour que au titre de la vie
commune qu'elle partage avec un homme
qui la bat alors nous lui devons de
prolonger son droit au séjour après la
séparation du couple
ce principe figurait déjà dans notre
droit il a été réaffirmée en novembre
2012 par une circulaire de manuel valls
alors ministre de l'intérieur mais j'ai
souvent été interpellé par des
parlementaires par des associations
attentive à la bonne application de ces
dispositions
il méritait donc que l'on y revienne
votre commission a clarifié ses
dispositions en inscrivant de manière
explicite que ce droit à la prolongation
du séjour est ouvert indépendamment du
fait que la victime où l'agresseur est
été à l'origine de la rupture
c'est une très bonne disposition qui
fait écho aux propositions de la
commission nationale consultative des
droits de l'homme
je vous en remercie votre commission a
également précisé les conditions dans
lesquelles doit être apprécié le
consentement au mariage ce qui apporte
aussi une réponse utile aux victimes
d'un mariage forcé commis à l'étranger
je serai donc évidemment favorables à
ces mesures
cette question des femmes étrangères
victimes de violences a donné lieu à de
nombreux amendements
certains anticipent l'examen à venir
d'un projet de loi sur l'immigration
je ne pourrai donc pas les soutenir
aujourd'hui viendra le temps de les
discuter dans les meilleures conditions
d'autres amendements viennent préciser
les circonstances dans lesquelles les
victimes de la traite des êtres humains
et du proxénétisme se voit garantir un
droit où ses jours lorsque les coupables
sont reconnues comme telles par la
justice je souhaite que nous puissions
trouver dans la discussion une piste en
effet permettant de renforcer ses droits
et l'oms et messieurs les sénateurs
si nous voulons changer de société les
images dégradantes des femmes les
violences qui leur sont faites les
stéréotypes sexistes ne doivent plus y
avoir droit de cité
cela doit être la règle aussi sur
internet
et c'est le sens de l'article 10
de ce projet de loi dont le but est bien
de permettre aux internautes de signaler
aux hébergeurs les propos homophobes en
defence sexistes et de rendre
obligatoire leur suppression
il revient à la loi de déterminer ces
bornes
il vous revient à vous législateur de
dire que le sexisme sous ses formes les
plus brutales comme les plus sournoises
ne relèvent jamais du simple mauvais
goût de l'inélégance du trait d'esprit
libre et impertinent
je serai donc défavorable à la
proposition de suppression de cet
article 17 que j'estime au contraire
très utile enfin concernant la parité
qui constitue un volet important de ce
texte
j'approuve les évolutions introduites
par votre commission pour limiter la
pénalité pesant sur les partis
politiques qui ne respectent pas la
parité
imiter cette pénalité à 150 % comme nous
l'avions initialement nous même proposé
c'est un point important car cela est de
nature à sécuriser le texte
du point de vue juridique je suivrai
également votre ligne s'agissant des
amendements qui tendent à renforcer la
parité
concernant les élections locales nous
reviendrons sans doute sur les détails
dans les détails sur ce sujet dans la
discussion
mais lorsque lorsque cette sécurité
juridique n'est pas en cause
je crois en revanche nécessaire
d'avancer résolument sur la parité
parce qu'on le sait bien sans
volontarisme sur ces sujets la société a
du mal à évoluer à s'inscrire dans une
dynamique paritaire qui forcément appel
à modifier les comportements comme les
modes d'organisation ça n'est jamais
simple mais il faut que nous prenions
ensemble ce parti-pris paritaire
ambitieux et réaliste qui s'inscrit dans
la durée
vous le voyez mesdames et messieurs les
sénateurs mon ambition au cours de cette
lecture c'est de conserver ce qui fait
la force de ce texte
il a été conçu pour être appliquées
doter des moyens pour changer
véritablement la donne
une fois qu'il sera confronté au réel je
sais que c'est un souhait que nous
partageons jeu
c'est les bonnes volontés jeu c'est
l'intransigeance jeu c'est l'exigence
est l'ambition de votre assemblée
j'espère que notre discussion et nos
conclusions pourront en témoigner je
vous remercie
merci madame la ministre
la parole est à virginie klès rapporteur
de la commission des lois
madame la présidente madame la ministre
mes chers collègues le texte dont nous
abordons la discussion aujourd'hui à une
importance et une ambition qui ont été
déjà reconnu par toutes et tous en
première lecture ne serait ce que par le
nombre du champ d'intervention que nous
avons relevé j'en veux simplement pour
preuve que je pense déjà connaître
quasiment les cabinets de tous les
nouveaux ministères ou presque suite aux
nombreux appels qui ont été passées pour
aborder tel ou tel domaine ou tel ou tel
sujet de ce texte de loi
retour de la navette retour de la
navette et finalement le texte il nous
revient n'est pas fondamentalement
changé il partage toujours les mêmes
objectifs
il y à des avancées il a des hommes et
améliorations même déjà grâce à
l'assemblée nationale mais pour un
certain nombre d'entre elles deux ces
avancées amélioration mais celle venir à
porter sur le fond pour un certain
nombre d'articles nous vous en parlera
beaucoup mieux que moi tout à l'heure
donc les objectifs restent inchangés et
partager créer les conditions créé
l'énorme créer l'environnement de droit
qui permettra à une société dans
laquelle nous reconnaîtrons et dans
laquelle chacune et chacun se verra
accorder un égal accès à toutes les
activités à toutes les responsabilités
et à tous les droits de chaque moment de
sa vie qu'ils soient hommes ou qu'ils
soient femmes l'assemblée nationale a
souhaité appeler cela l'égalité réelle
la commission des lois qui est de
tradition attaché à une loi la moins
bavarde possible dépouillé parfois
d'adjectifs quand ils peuvent être
re prêter quand leur interprétation peut
affaiblir les mots alors qu'il voudrait
les affirmer encore plus la commission
des lois propose donc de revenir à la
simple égalité la simple l'entière
légalité tout simplement aimer beaucoup
est moins fort que aimé et d'égalité
réelle assemblée à la commission des
lois moins forte que l'égalité la devise
de la république c'est liberté égalité
fraternité et nous semble vraiment que
ce serait affaiblir une fois plus les
mots que de parler d'égalité réelle
c'est pour cette raison et pas pour une
autre que nous proposons d'en revenir
aux intitulés ou titre initial de ceux
de ce projet de loi sur les autres
amendements pour un certain nombre
d'entre eux la commission des lois vous
a proposé ou vous proposera des
suppressions parce que certaines
dispositions étaient redondantes
existait déjà dans la loi et c'est
toujours à faiblir un texte que de
mettre des dispositions identiques dans
deux textes différents
quand on en change 1 on oublie parfois
de changer l'autre et le droit devient
contradictoires et donc une fois plus
affaiblie pour autant pour autant d'en
parler est une bonne chose parce que si
certains ou certaines ont pensé à
rajouter des dispositions dans la loi
c'est qu'ils ignoraient que ces
dispositions existaient déjà et donc il
n'est pas inutile de le rappeler à
l'occasion du débat mais pour autant il
nous semblait inutile et peut-être même
une fois plus affaiblir le texte que de
les y laisser certaines notre
disposition nous ensemble et non
applicable c'est pourquoi nous avons
préféré aussi les supprimer enfin
certains étaient simplement symbolique
ou déclaratoire là encore nous avons
préféré les retirer du texte de loi même
si pour la même raison
précédemment il nous semble important
d'en parler de les mettre au débat et
que ce soit repris par les médias par la
communication pour que tout le monde
sache que nous en partageons bien
évidemment la volonté et les ambitions
mais que la loi n'est pas forcément où
est inutilement le vecteur pour
l'épauler d'y inscrire il en est ainsi
par exemple sur l'ensemble de ces
de ces modifications proposées par la
commission des lois des calendriers et
des règles de représentativité des
femmes et des hommes dans un certain
nombre d'instances sportifs
professionnels ou culturelles ou dans un
certain nombre d'instances où la
république l'état à une part de
responsabilité en matière de nomination
nous vous avons donc proposé nous vous
proposons de revenir à la rédaction
initiale du sénat parce qu'il nous
semble que c'est plus réaliste et donc
plus efficace que de prendre un peu plus
de temps sur un certain de fait de
nomination et de prendre le temps de
faire quelques étapes et de monter
progressivement un certain nombre de
marches en matière de droit du travail
là où ils existent encore oui de
nombreuses inégalités tant de
rémunération temps d'accès à certains
postes que de prise en compte des
responsabilités de déroulement de
carrière donc l'assemblée nationale
apporte un certain nombre
d'améliorations et notre commission des
affaires sociales on a apporté d'autres
encore mais une fois de plus michel
meunier sera bien plus qualifiés que moi
pour vous en pour vous en parler je ne
m'étendrai donc pas là dessus mais au
delà de toutes ces mesures
au-delà de ces coups de pied dans la
fourmilière qu'il faut parfois donné
imposer des quotas imposés des
calendriers pour avancer nos
prédécesseurs l'ont fait madame la
ministre l'a rappelé tout à l'heure avec
la loi de 44 et le droit des femmes à la
fois de voter et d'être éligible j
rajouterai parce que c'est une team date
vous parliez madame la ministre tout à
l'heure d'un certain nombre de dates il
ya notre dette qui personnellement mais
cher c 1961
tout simplement parce que c'est mon
année de naissance et qu'en 1961 ma mère
a enfin eu le droit de travailler sans a
demandé l'autorisation à mon père
puisque la loi à l'époque ne l'autorisé
pas sans à travailler sans en demander
la permission à son époux donc voilà il
ya des coups de pieds comme ça temps en
temps dans la fourmilière qui est
important de donner pour faire bouger
les choses et pour contraindre à
construire ou à re construire autre
chose donc un certain nombre de mesures
relèvent encore peut-être un peu de ses
coups de pied qui sont sans doute un peu
plus mesuré parce qu'on a heureusement
progresser depuis et pas forcément tout
à fait tout à fait les mêmes besoins
on mesure d'ailleurs un petit peu malgré
tous les effets de ces coups de pied
donné par nos prédécesseurs au
prédécesseuse sur le sujet pour moi le
grand mérite sans doute le plus grand
mérite de ce texte de loi et qu'il
s'intéresse aux enfants il s'intéresse
aux enfants dans tous ses aspects oui
bien évidemment dans toutes les mesures
concernant les violences conjugales mais
pas uniquement
pas uniquement parce que l'enfant se
construit à partir de sa naissance sur
le langage qu'il a autour de lui sur le
langage qui consiste en des mots mais en
des comportements il construit son
regard sur la société
il construit sur son regard sur les
rôles les hommes et des femmes
ils construisent en regard sur son
propre rôle au sein de cette société en
tant que garçon fille en tant que futur
homme ou future femme sur l'exemple
qu'il a autour de lui
cet exemple qui dans un premier temps et
la cellule familiale très resserré
papa maman éventuellement les frères et
des soeurs puis l'école avec les
enseignants avec les copains les copines
puis le cadre au delà de l'école le
cadre estudiantin et le cadre de travail
chacun se construit tout au long de sa
vie sur ces exemples de comportements de
mots de langage autour de lui et ce
qu'il fait souffrance aussi bien à
l'adulte cas l'enfant d'abord à l'enfant
puis à l'adulte c'est l'écart éventuel
entre différents langages relationnel
qui se situe autour de lui l'enfant qui
apprend chez lui à langage relationnel
faits de violence fait d'humiliation
fait de domination de l'un de ses
parents par rapport à l'autre ne se
retrouve pas dans ce langage à l'école
et selon sa personnalité selon qu'il est
lui il se construira différemment il
arrivera à se construire quand même où
il n'y arrivera pas il arrivera à
combler cette souffrance où il n'y
arrivera pas et s'ils n'arrivent pas à
la combler cette souffrance elle ne fera
que se développer encore plus une fois
adolescent plus une fois jeunes adultes
puis une fois adulte et c'est pour ça
qu'il est primordial me semble-t-il de
s'attaquer effectivement à tous les
niveaux de la société pour que le
comportement de chacun soient
respectueux de l'autre homme ou femme
père ou mère époux épouse
subordonnée ou responsables
hiérarchiques dans ce texte de loin il y
à des mesures pour protéger aussi les
pères et pour les impliquer plus dans
l'éducation de leurs enfants se sont
donc nécessairement une bonne mesure et
elles vont nécessairement contribué à
cette construction d'une société plus
respectueuse des uns et des autres dans
ce texte de loi
il ya aussi tout ce volet sur les
violences conjugales
il me semble important aussi la
d'insister sur la formation qui est
encore un peu modifié un petit peu
élargie dans le texte que nous revient
aujourd'hui sur la formation
professionnelle en matière de violence
conjugale
la violence physique elle est facile
entre guillemets avoir à percevoir et
elle est toujours condamné la violence
physique elle n'est pas forcément le
fabuleux emprise psychologique elle
n'est pas forcément le fait d'un
mécanisme de violences répétées la
violence physique elle peut être le fait
d'un conflit ponctuelles qui est à
condamner mais elle peut elle peut
procéder de mécanismes en amont très
différents les uns des autres et quand
la justice à avoir à juger à regarder ce
qu'il se passe entre deux personnes y
compris marié femmes y compris pères et
mères avec des phénomènes de violence
physique exprimer il est primordial
qu'on se pose la question de quel est ce
phénomène de violence qui est en face de
moi est-ce que j'ai le sentiment que la
victime supporte quelque chose qui est
venu totalement anormal et qu'elle ne
devrait pas supporter ou est-ce que la
victime finalement se tourner vers la
justice
juste au moment où elle a pris elle a
pris un coup qu'elle n'aurait pas dû
prendre
est-ce que sa réaction est immédiate ou
est-ce que sa réaction n'est pas
immédiate et se poser cette simple
question amène déjà à essayer de
comprendre par quels mécanismes la
victime en arrive aujourd'hui devant la
justice
s
un conflit ponctuelles même violent ou
est ce qu'on dit sur un autre phénomène
d'emprise psychologie ou est-ce qu'on
est sur un autre phénomène par exemple
de victimes de traite des êtres humains
par exemple de chantage quel qu'il soit
par exemple de de fatigue mutuel des
deux membres du couple
il faut vraiment se poser ces questions
il faut comprendre ses mécanismes et
pour cela il est nécessaire
indispensable que chacun dans la chaîne
de la justice se forment la force des
coups elle est évidente
une fois de plus des coups physiques la
force des mots elle est encore méconnu
j'aurais aimé que chacun d'entre vous en
ai rencontré de ces hommes de ces femmes
et même de ces enfants qui vous explique
pendant 5 ans 10 ans 15 ans 20 ans j'ai
entendu tous les jours tu es folle tu es
complètement malade ma pauvre mais
qu'est ce que tu lis là encore comme
bêtises ah si tu savais ce que tes amis
pensent de toi
memon pauvreté même pas capable de
ramener un salaire correct à la maison
tu te fais bouffer par tous tes
collègues mais ton patron il se moque de
toi et toi tu crois vraiment que tu va
progresser dans sa carrière
mes attentes et coller mais elle rigole
de toi mais si tu les entendais parler
de toi ça paraît anodin sa parano dames
et pourtant ces mots répéter tous les
jours tous les jours pendant des années
sur tous les modes sur tous les tons
ce sont ces mots qui détruisent et sont
ses mots qui traque
ce sont ces mots qui harcèlent qui
hantent qui fera plus dur que des coups
physiques parfois ce sont ces mots là
qui pousse un certain nombre d'hommes de
femmes ou d'enfants au suicide et à la
détresse et ce sont ces détresses là que
la justice doit apprendre à reconnaître
et à reconnaître vite et ne pas renvoyer
l'homme ou la femme qui a trouvé un jour
le courage de pousser la barrière de ces
mots de pousser la barrière de la
justice de venir chercher du secours
ne pas renvoyer cet homme ou cette femme
dans les bras ou sous les mots de son
bourg bureau bourreau titre de
l'infraction insuffisamment caractérisée
au titre deux ans quand même vous avez
qu à vous défendre un petit
mais après tout pourquoi vous rester
avec lui avec elle non il est vraiment
je crois de notre devoir que de faire en
sorte que la justice entendent simo les
reconnaissent et aident ces personnes
aident ces victimes
je me rappelle cette femme cadre
supérieur qui était tellement surveillé
par son mari que chaque fois qu'elle
sortait quelque part elle rentrait avec
ces tickets de métro ou de bus et
l'heure à laquelle elles avaient pris le
métro ou le bus et la station qui
laissait son téléphone portable sur la
table parce qu'ils devaient contrôler
les communications qu'elle avait passé
jusqu'au jour où elle s'est dit c'est
pas possible
jusqu'au jour où elle s'est enfin dit je
vis pas une vie normale et jusqu'au jour
elle est allée voir la justice
elle est allée voir une avocate elle est
rentrée bien évidemment il avait monté
tout son cinéma
elle était soit disant allez justement
au cinéma elle avait prise en tickets de
séance au cinéma elle est rentrée à la
donne et sans tickets de séance de
cinéma à son mari et le ticket de bus à
côté
elle s'est trompée elle a pas donné le
bon ticket de bus a donné le ticket de
bus qu'il avait servi à les voir son
avocate elle a fini sous les coups ce
jour là jusque là il y avait peut être
coup ce jour là elle a fini sous les
coups cadres supérieurs je pense aussi à
cet homme cadres supérieurs qui m'a dit
un jour les coudes c'est une femme tu me
vois moi je suis quand même assez grand
et assez costaud
quentin pour un truc pour me connaissent
et devant nos deux gamines je vais quand
même pas me mettre à lui cogner dessus
là mon tour donc je suis parti
et puis c'est la mère de mes enfants je
vais quand même pas porté plainte contre
elle alors je suis parti avec mes
valises et j'ai laissé mes filles je
pense à cet autre homme homosexuel qui
se faisait humilier en permanence par
son concubin qui pouvait pas partir on
en parlera tout à l'heure à propos de
logement parce que le logement était à
son nom parce que le concubin avait fait
changer la serrure
ces thèmes là aussi il faut l'entendre
je pense à cette femme aussi
cet homme qui s'était réfugiée chez ses
parents avec sa petite fille son bébé
et son ancien compagnon dont elle était
pourtant séparés mais que la justice
n'avait pas suffisamment pris en compte
qui a continué de harceler ses parents
ses amis son nouveau concubin jusqu'à
les tuer son père un jour chez elle et
ses parents
ces violences la ces situations là la
justice doit les reconnaître et elle ne
le reconnaîtra que quand enfin on aura
tellement parlé qu'on aura tellement
formé de gens qu'on saura les
reconnaître et les distinguer parce que
c'est primordial
les distinguer des cas de conflits
violents ponctuelles qui ne nécessitent
pas la même prise en compte et la même
prise en charge
tout cela ce sera me semble-t-il une
réalité demain grâce un certain nombre
de dispositions qu'ils sont dans ce
texte de loi les dispositions sur la
formation pluridisciplinaire et qu'on
pourrait peut-être encore amélioré mais
là ça ne relève pas de la loi donc je ne
demande pas ce que ce soit inscrit dans
la loi mais qu'on en parle améliorée
avec le rôle des magistrats
coordonnateur que madame tasca notre
collecte à ce cas et notre collègue
mercier ont cité dans leur rapport sur
la justice familiale sans doute un rôle
supplémentaire pourrait-il être donnée à
ce magistrat coordonnateur poursuivre
effectivement tous ces dossiers tous ces
cas tous et toutes ces personnes qui
subissent des violences conjugales ou
qui sont auteurs de violences conjugales
s'occuper des auteurs c'est aussi
protéger des futures victimes de façon à
donner une meilleure connaissance de ce
phénomène concret pratique dans leurs
juridictions se poser les questions
c'est une disposition que je propose
dans ce nouveau dans ce texte de loi
en contraignant pas beaucoup contraindre
la justice mais en contraignant la
justice à se poser des questions et à se
poser notamment la question à chaque
fois qu'une condamnation pour violence
se posera sera prononcée en assises ou
en correctionnelle il y a des enfants
que fait-on des enfants quelle est la
personnalité réelle de la personne que
je suis en train de condamner cas
l'autorité parentale
quel mode de garde pour les enfants mode
de garde pour les enfants je ne peux pas
passer sous silence l'amendement
notre collègue buzzer qui va revenir en
discussion tout à l'heure sur la garde
des enfants aussi oui il y aura des
questions se posent et je suis pas
certaine que l'amendement de notre
collègue mézard soit vraiment sa place
ici est vraiment correctement rédigé
mais en tout cas sur le fond il a raison
oui il faut se poser la question aussi
souvent que possible la construction des
enfants passent par cette question à se
poser dès qu'il a des violences entre un
père et une mère
la médiation pénale est aussi un moment
il faut se poser la question je pense
contrairement à certains d'entre nous
qu'il faut maintenir une médiation
pénale il faut garder cet outil à la
main mais en se posant la question
faut-il vraiment que je prononce une
médiation pénale car je ne me
prononcerai qu'une seule il ne faut pas
que je me trompe il faut vraiment que je
la prononce à bon escient
si j'ai le moindre doute je ne prononce
pas de médiation pénale et je considère
que je suis sur un cas de violence avec
emprise s'il n'est pas de doute je
prononce médiation pénale et on réglera
mieux et plus facilement le problème
pour faire attention à ne pas tout
qualifié de violence avec emprise au
risque au là encore de fragiliser la
formation de fragiliser la connaissance
que l'on a pas encore complète mais que
l'on a quand même déjà de ce phénomène
les questions sont nombreuses aussi en
matière de dépaysement en cas de
harcèlement sexuel
la question a été posée et des réponses
sont apportées je pense l'assemblée
nationale a déjà amélioré les choses et
je pense qu'aujourd'hui le texte va
aboutir sa quelque chose de construit
une catégorie quand même que je ne peux
pas oublier même si j'aime pas beaucoup
catégoriser les gens ce sont les
agricultrices
les agricultrices victimes de violences
conjugales
c'est agricultrice qui du coup veulent
quitter l'exploitation et qui ont été
bénéficiaires des aides à l'installation
et qui se retrouvent en double peine
parce qu'aujourd'hui le dispositif qui
d'ordre réglementaire mais une fois de
plus on est là pour parler aussi de ce
qui est d'ordre réglementaire même sur
l'inscrira pas dans la loi mais c'est
agricultrice peuvent se retrouver ayant
quitté le domicile conjugal à rembourser
des aides à l'exploitation qu'elles vont
perçu alors que décemment elles ne
peuvent plus rester avec leur conjoint a
su bien les phénomènes de violences
qu'elles subissent et puis madame la
ministre vous l'avez évoqué beaucoup
d'amendements beaucoup de propositions
concernant le droit des étrangers
la commission des lois bien évidemment
est d'accord sur le fond avec un certain
nombre d'entre eux deux ces amendements
là parce qu'on partage les objectifs
mais il est sans doute nécessaire de
trouver un autre véhicule législatif
plus large mieux adaptés qui prendra
l'ensemble des conséquences de ces
propositions en considération les
améliorera d'ailleurs sans doute encore
qui sera peut-être plus large dans
certains cas mais est pour ces raisons
et non pas parce qu'on n'en partageait
pas les objectifs
la commission des lois a émis
effectivement un avis défavorable un
certain nombre de ces amendements en
parler aujourd'hui sera une bonne chose
et fera de toute façon avancer le débat
qui aura lieu très prochainement sur les
droits des étrangers sur le sujet ici
dans cette enceinte et à l'assemblée
nationale aussi voilà pour toutes ces
raisons je crois que vous les partager
je vous inviterai bien évidemment en fin
de séance a voté le texte qui nous est
présenté merci merci chers collègues
la parole est un autre collègue michel
munier rapporteur pour la commission des
affaires sociales madame la présidente
madame la ministre mes chers collègues
sans reprendre ce qui a été dit dans cet
hémicycle en première lecture je
souhaite toutefois revenir en quelques
mots sur la genèse est l'objet de ce
texte
il s'appuie d'abord sur des constats
celui du long chemin parcouru au cours
du 20e siècle notamment pour que les
femmes obtiennent leurs droits
fondamentaux
je cite à mon tour madame la ministre
l'exemple fortement emblématique d'une
actualité presque au jour près l'accès
au droit de vote et d'éligibilité
obtenus par les femmes
le 21 avril 1944 il y à 70 ans ce fut
indéniablement une étape importante mais
encore insuffisante pour permettre aux
femmes de prendre toute leur place dans
le domaine politique et décisionnel de
notre pays nous pouvons faire les même
constat dans la sphère professionnelle
le partage des tâches domestiques et
éducatives
l'accès au loisir et au sport où les
inégalités restent encore criantes
aujourd'hui de même la protection des
filles et des femmes de notre pays face
aux violences restent insuffisantes
dans tous ces domaines des textes
existent mais des pratiques résiste
c'est sur ce constat que se fondent la
démarche engagée dans ce projet de loi
qui vise à mobiliser tous les leviers
possibles pour faire appliquer les
textes modifier les comportements et
atteindre enfin l'égalité réelle
c'est la démarche engagée sans relâche
par madame la ministre aux droits des
femmes que je remercie sincèrement pour
son action et pour les mesures concrètes
qu'elles ne cessent de mettre en place
pour la fair pour faire appliquer les
textes bousculer l'ordre des choses et
faire reculer ces inégalités qui entache
encore notre démocratie
vous avez le choix madame la ministre
d'agir de manière transversale dans
toutes les sphères de la société à
travers un texte ambitieux exigeant et
terriblement nécessaire
cette deuxième lecture nous démontrent
s'il en est besoin la volonté commune du
gouvernement et des parlementaires de
faire avancer l'égalité si chère à notre
pays
il couvre ainsi les grandes thématiques
où les inégalités entre les sexes sont
encore importants la vie de famille bien
sûr la sphère professionnelle
la précarité qui frappe d'abord les
femmes les violences envers les filles
et les femmes produits de notre société
où la domination des hommes est encore
manifeste et enfin la question de la
parité dans les instances politiques et
décisionnel urgence démocratique s'il en
est parmi ces différents axes la
commission des lois a décidé de léguer à
la commission des affaires sociales dont
je suis la rapporteure l'examen au fond
de 32 articles sur les 93 restant en
discussion
il s'agit principalement des mesures qui
ont trait aux serres familiale et
professionnelle
avant d'en venir aux amendements votés
par la commission je souhaite souligner
les principales avancées a adopté par
l'assemblée nationale
tout d'abord les dispositions en faveur
d'un partage plus équitable des
responsabilités parentales la plus
emblématique d'entre elles inscrite à
l'article 2 est l'instauration d'une
période de partage des droits aux est
une période de partage des droits au
complément de libre choix pardon entre
les parents pour inciter les pères à
réduire ou interrompre leur activité
professionnelle pour s'occuper de leurs
enfants afin de prendre toute leur place
dans la vie familiale et d'améliorer le
retour à l'emploi des mères qui le
souhaitent à mon initiative le sénat
avait décidé de modifier le nom du clc à
en prestation partager d'accueil de
l'enfant l'assemblée nationale propose
dans le même esprit de la nommer
prestation partager d'éducation de
l'enfant et cette dénomination me
convient tout à fait le dispositif a été
complété sur plusieurs points le congé
parental pourra dans le cas de
naissances multiples d'au moins trois
enfants être prolongée jusqu'au sixième
anniversaire des enfants de même le
bénéfice du montant majoré de la
prestation partagé sera possible à titre
expérimental dès l'arrivée du deuxième
enfant
en ce qui concerne la santé des femmes
l'assemblée a modifié le titre de la
deuxième partie du code de la santé
publique qui était jusqu'à lors intitulé
santé de la famille de la mère et de
l'enfant
l'assemblée nationale a proposé de la
renommée santé reproductive droits de la
femme et protection de la santé de
l'enfant afin de reconnaître
explicitement les droits des femmes en
matière de santé notamment sur la
maîtrise de leur sexualité
dans le même esprit l'assemblée a
également introduit un nouvel article 5
pièces et qui supprime la référence à
l'état de détresse pour une femme
demandant une ivg
je soutiens fortement cette nouvelle
formulation de l'article l 22 12-1 du
code de la santé publique qui permet
d'affirmer sans ambiguïté
le droit des femmes à disposer de leur
corps et âme à choisir le recours à liv
et j'ai pour des raisons qui leur
appartiennent
nous savons les femmes responsables en
la matière revenons-en à l'égalité
professionnelle entre les femmes et les
hommes
l'assemblée nationale a renforcé le
rapport de situation comparée afin d'en
faire un outil de mesure des écarts de
rémunération et de promotion
professionnelle qui s'accumulent au
cours d'une carrière
les députés ont également attribué des
droits au père autour de la naissance
d'un enfant en autorisant trois absences
pour accompagner leur campagne aux
examens prénataux et en instituant une
protection contre le licenciement
pendant les quatre semaines qui suivent
la naissance si cette dernière
disposition a été supprimée en
commission des lois
je propose pour ma part de la
réintroduire car elle contribue au
partage plus équilibré des
responsabilités parentales
l'article 5 waters a encouragé les
entreprises à mieux prendre en compte
l'exposition des femmes salariées face
aux risques professionnels
rappelons ici que le nombre d'accidents
du travail a diminué chez les hommes
durant les dix dernières années mais
qu'il a progressé de plus de 20 % chez
les femmes
j'en terminerai par les pros
dispositions relatives à la lutte contre
la précarité
peu de modifications sont intervenues
par rapport au texte présenté en
première lecture
si ce n'est des précisions techniques
porté à l'article 6 visant à mieux
protéger les parents vivent seules avec
leurs enfants contre les impayés de
pension alimentaire
en outre deux articles introduits au
sénat ont été enrichis l'article 6 qu'un
pièce qui ouvre aux bénéficiaires de la
prestation partage et d'éducation une
priorité d'accès aux places de crèche
l'article 6 7 pièces qui engage
l'expérimentation du tiers payant du
complément de libre choix de mode de
garde pour les familles modestes
je propose pour ma part dans un
amendement d'élargir cette possibilité
aux familles modestes qui ont recours à
une garde d'enfant à domicile ou en
micro crèche
il s'agit de limiter les avances
d'argent aux familles ayant des budgets
très serrés et ainsi de soutenir leur
accès ou leur maintien dans l'activité
professionnelle l'assemblée a également
introduit le nouvel article 23 bis à qui
vise à assurer de manière progressive
la parité au sein des conseils
d'administration des caisses nationales
de sécurité sociale ou la présence des
femmes restent encore trop modeste je
vous propose maintenant une rapide
présentation des amendements adoptés par
la commission des affaires sociales 16
amendements ont été adoptés
il s'agit principalement d'amendements
rédactionnelle de précision
d'harmonisation coordination juridique
gens soulignent quatre tout d'abord la
précision porté à l'article 2 g afin que
le rapport remis par les branches à la
commission nationale de la négociation
collective et aux conseils supérieurs de
l'égalité professionnelle soit un outil
efficace au cercle au service de la
lutte contre les discriminations
professionnelles
j'ai pris l'initiative de redéposer cet
amendement dont les dispositions ont été
écartés par la commission des lois de
notre assemblée afin de lutter contre la
précarité des femmes
nous avons également souhaité permettre
aux familles monoparentales de
bénéficier de la durée étendue du
versement de la prestation partager même
dans le cas d'une remise en couple
à l'issue de la période initiale de
versement nous proposons également la
prolongation de six mois de la durée
d'expérimentation du versement du
montant majoré de la prestation partager
aux parents de deux enfants prestation
qui est actuellement réservé aux
familles de trois enfants et plus nous
souhaitons ainsi mieux mesurer
l'incidence de cette initiative sur le
retour à l'emploi de ses bénéficiaires
à l'issue du congé parental cette
expérimentation sera lancée au 1er
janvier 2015 par la cnaf
nous avons enfin préciser les modalités
d'observation et d'évaluation des
risques professionnels des salariés à
mettre en oeuvre par l'employeur afin de
mettre l'accent sur la différence des
tâches confiées aux femmes et le risque
qu'elle comporte
le travail autour de ce texte sur
l'égalité
et entre les femmes et les hommes a
fortement mobilisé notre commission le
texte qui est présenté aujourd'hui
comporte de réelles avancées dont nous
devrons suivre avec une grande vigilance
la mise en application dans les fêtes
c'est ça l'égalité réelle
car si l'égalité des droits est inscrite
au préambule de notre constitution
l'égalité effective
reste à construire encore et toujours
j'aimerais terminer mon propos en
insistant sur la fierté que nous pouvons
ressentir en voyant notre pays
réaffirmé par ce projet de loi son
ambition d'une société plus juste et
plus égalitaire
une ambition qui s'accompagne de moyens
et de levier très concret nous le savons
bien
l'égalité réelle ne se décrète pas elle
se construit et ce projet de loi apporte
une pierre importante à l'édifice je
vous remercie
voilà vous avez donc pu suivre l'examen
du projet de loi sur l'égalité femmes
hommes
un texte examiné par le sénat en
deuxième lecture tout de suite la suite
de nos programmes sur public sénat
les qualités tous ont les mêmes droits